اندوني بلينكن بان الكونجرس
سيدرج روسيا على قائمة الدول
صواريخ في الشرق الاوسط محذرا من
ان الصواريخ والمسيارات
النفطية. احتجاجات واسعة في
بغداد تطالب برد قوي ضد انقرة
شن عملية عسكرية في سوريا
والعراق. واشنطن تتوقع غزوا
بالمائة من احتياطات الغاز في
العالم بسبعين تريليون متر مكعب
رئيسة مجلس النواب الامريكي
نانسي اخبرت وزير الخارجية
الاشتباكات في طرابلس الى ثلاثة
عشر قتيلا. اكبر صفقة في تاريخ
للنفط مع عملاق الطاقة الروسي
الحكومي جاز بروم بقيمة اجمالية
صينيا لتايوان والجنرال تشارلز
فلين يقول يمكننا مساعدة تايوان
الراعية للارهاب اذا لم تقم
الخارجية بذلك. ارتفاع حصيلة
من خلال ابقاء سياستنا الموحدة
تجاه الصين. قال مدير وكالة
اربعين مليار دولار امريكي تشمل
تطوير ثلاثة حقول غاز وستة حقول
وتدعو لطرد السفير التركي وقطع
العلاقات مع تركيا العراق يهدد
اقليم الزاخو في العراق هجوم
بطائرتين مسيرتين مفخختين
خطوط انابيب لتصدير الغاز الى
الخارج ايران وروسيا لهما دور
مولوجا ووش اوغلو ان تركيا لا
تطلب الاذن مطلقا من اي احد قبل
صناعة النفط والغاز الايراني
توقعها الشركة الوطنية ان ايكو
نفطية في ايران واكمال مشروعات
الغاز الطبيعي المسال وانشاء
باللجوء الى مجلس الامن ضد
انقرة. قال وزير الخارجية التركي
الاستخبارات المركزية الامريكية
ان ايران تمتلك اكبر ترسانة
الايرانية تشكل تهديدا متزايد
الاهمية. قال موقع بوليتكو ان
استهدفتا قاعدة للجيش التركي
شمالي العراق لكن الجيش التركي
مهم في استدامة الطاقة العالمية
اذ تمتلكان ما يعادل ثلاثين
العالم. وهي الطائرة الوحيدة من
الطائرات ذات المهام
افلتت من اربعة الاف صاروخ حاولت
اسقاطها صنعت لمهام استخباراتية
من الغاز. بين يحاول الغرب زيادة
العقوبات استطاع الدب الروسي
عاد واستهدف بالمدفعية مصيف بورخ
بداهوك. الضربات التركية طالت
الاستراتيجية التي لم تفقد قط
احدا من افراد طاقمها لكن وفي
من حرب اوكرانيا. فهل يعي
الاسرائيليون الدرس جيدا? اختراق
زالت تبدو وكانها شيء من
المستقبل. انها الطائرة
تكلفة تشغيلها الباهظة ولم تستطع
اي طائرة حتى الان تعويض الطائر
تجسسية لا تضاهى تسير كالبرق
الخاطف صممت في الماضي لكنها لا
من افضالهم عليه. الطائر الاسود.
اسرع جاسوس في العالم. قدرات
الاسود. الاحداث والتطورات. بعد
مرور يومين على استهداف منتجع
التي يمكن للشركة نقلها بعد ذلك
الى الصين. هناك بدأت واشنطن
الرئيس جو بايدن حظر دخول جميع
منتجات هواوي الى الولايات
معلمته التي دعاها لقصر الرئاسة.
لم يضع بوتين في اعتباره اي
الثمانينية بين احضانه. ويقبلها
على جبينها. في مشهد يعكس الى اي
الامريكية كانت زالت الاسرع في
العالم منذ الحرب الباردة. وقد
عام تسعة وثمانين كانت اخر
مهامها. وخرجت من الخدمة بسبب
درجة يحترم بوتين معلمته. لن
يكون ذلك غريبا على بوتين. الذي
خلال مقابلة زعماء العالم لا
يبدو بنفس القوة عندما قابل
لديها القدرة على تصوير ما يعادل
مائتين وستين كيلو مترا مربع.
تشعر بالقلق من لشركة هواوي على
بيانات حساسة عن التدريبات
هذه الانتهاكات في العراق مع انه
يمتلك اقوى المقاتلين ويمتلك
السماح لها بشن هجمات في سوريا
كما تريد. فما الذي يفكر به
وجه الارض. لكن الرجل الذي يتمتع
بكل هذا القدر من القوة والنفوذ
بوتين. لاديمير بوتين الذي عرف
بانه الرئيس الاكثر صلابة على
تحقيقها مع الشركة الصينية. ولكن
لم تصل لاي نتيجة الشك ينخر عقول
وتجسسية فهي تلتقط الصور بدقة
بالغة لمواقع عسكرية حول العالم.
بروتوكول او شروط سلامة. ولم
يفكر سوى ان يأخذ معلمته
سبق ان زار معلمه في جهاز
الاستخبارات فقط ليسلم على ويكرم
منذ اطلاقها عام الف وتسعمائة
وستة وستين قامت بالاف حول
المتحدة. فهل يكون قلق واشنطن في
محله ام انها مجرد اوهام? انحناء
الاحياء السكنية. فلماذا كل هذا
السكوت من المجتمع الدولي على
الوكالة التي تحاول تجميع شتات
اليهود المتفرقين في العالم. لكن
بوتين دائما ما يذكر معلميه
بالخير ليرد كما يقول ولو جزءا
القواعد الامريكية. بحسب وكالة
رويترز فان السلطات الامريكية
العسكرية وحالة جاهزية القواعد
والافراد عبر معدات الاتصالات
وروسيا واوكرانيا وتركيا لتفتيش
سفن الحبوب لعدم نقل الاسلحة وسط
الامريكان. لكن لا احد يجيب عن
اسئلتهم. الوكالة تقول ان ادارة
ارضاء بوتين. لكن اكثر ما يهم
دولة الكيان هو ان تواصل روسيا
تل ابيب يقول ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين غير راض عن تولي
العالم لكن بهذه الاتفاقية رفع
الغرب بعضا من عقوباته على روسيا
غضب بوتين سيوقف وصول اليهود من
روسيا الى تل ابيب بسبب موقفهم
الروسية طلبت تصفية روسي لوكالة
اليهود المعنية بالهجرة. هذه
نتيجة لكل ما يحدث قد تختفي من
الخارطة والسبب هو خطاياهم
ايها الغربيون يقولها بوتين.
موسكو وتل ابيب. السفير الروسي
الروس بخصوص اسرائيل ليس ذلك
فحسب. حتى ان وزارة العدل
وروسيا من بين اكبر الدول
المصدرة للمواد الغذائية في
كما تقول الخارجية الروسية اذا
فلماذا اتعبتم انفسكم بالعقوبات
الاتفاقية. الامم المتحدة اعلن
انشاء لجنة مشتركة من المنظمة
طاولة واحدة. سنعيش بدون نفط
وبدون غاز كما فعل اباؤنا
ارلافيد رئاسة الحكومة
الاسرائيلية. اسرائيل تحاول
ترحيب دولي واسع بالاتفاق. لكن
ممثلا روسيا واوكرانيا وقعا على
باستئناف شحنها للحبوب عبر
موانئها الثلاثة في البحر الاسود
الى اسواق العالم برعاية الامم
المتحدة وتركيا كضامنتين لهذه
وتجبر الغرب على قبول شروطها.
نعم يا سادة. روسيا واوكرانيا
توقعان اتفاقية تاريخية وغير
مسبوقة في اسطنبول تسمح لكيه
الاوكراني بالاضافة الى مقاتلات
هجومية من نوع اي عشرة. الرد جاء
من حدود روسيا سيتسبب بموت جزء
كبير من البشرية. فما الذي يقصده
تتضمن توفير مقاتلات اف ستة عشر
واف خمسة عشر لسلاح الجو
انه يبحث تزويد كييف بمقاتلات
حربية في تحول عن رفضه السابق
وروسيا لا تتحمل المسؤولية.
واضاف ميدفيديف ان اقتراب النيتو
يا ترى? اتفاق للتاريخ. روسيا
تدير حرب الحبوب بمنتهى الحنكة
اسرائيل عن رضا الدب الروسي؟ ها!
يا للعجب! هكذا اخترقت الصين
بسقف محدد لنوعية المساعدات
العسكرية التي ترسلها لاوكرانيا
لذلك وكشفت صحيفة وول ستريت
جورنال ان الخيارات الامريكية
من موسكو بلسان ميدفيديف رئيس
روسيا سابقا اوكرانيا كدولة
كهذه? وايران تبرم اكبر صفقة في
تاريخها مع روسيا. ما هذه
الصفقة? ما قبل المواجهة. لا
تزال الولايات المتحدة تحتفظ
لكن طارئا استجد على احتمالات
توسيع ذلك. اذ اكد البيت الابيض
للاعتراف بروسيا كراعية للارهاب.
فهل يجرؤ الامريكان على خطوة
اوكرانيا لن يكون لها على وجه
الارض. فما هذه التصعيدات
الاولون. ولكن ان بدون غذاء فهذه
هي الكارثة. وتعد اوكرانيا
ترد بالمدفعية وهذه هي النتائج.
واشنطن تعترف بقوة ايران وتسعى
الاتفاق بشكل منفصل دون ان
يتصافحا ولم يجلسا سويا على
فما هو هذا الطائر بوتين غير راض
عن اسرائيل؟ لكن لماذا تبحث
القواعد العسكرية في الولايات
المتحدة ورد عسكري عراقي! وتركيا
امام من؟ واول اتفاقية صلح بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا ولكن دون
الخطيرة؟ امريكا تتباهى بالطائر
الاسود اسرع جاسوس في العالم.
مصافحة. وواشنطن تدرس تزويد كييف
بمقاتلات حربية. وموسكو ترد بان
فلما كل هذا ايها الدب الروسي.
بوتين ينحني خوفا ورهبة ولكن
اوكرانيا قد تختفي من الخارطة
بسبب خطاياهم. هكذا تقولها روسيا
تخفيفها فكيف للغرب ان يسقط
الروس اذا?